imágenes granuladas de las primeras
horas de la mañana del viernes que
muestran la central nuclear más grande
de europa en llamas ahora bajo control
ruso la planta de energía nuclear de
sapo erija en el sureste del país fue
objeto de fuertes bombardeos el viernes
el fuego se extinguió rápidamente pero
el incidente recordó al mundo los
peligros extremos que rodean a la
energía nuclear la polilla es una de las
cuatro plantas activas en ucrania con 15
reactores que generan más de la mitad de
la energía del país pero también hay un
puñado de plantas cerradas como la de
chernobyl una fuga en cualquiera de
estas instalaciones podría ser mortal
los expertos se apresuraron a enfatizar
los peligros de las acciones de rusia
cuando tiene plantas de energía nuclear
activas es una receta para el desastre y
lo que se necesita es un fusil que se
dispara o algunos bombardeos que
resultan en un incendio si el fuego no
si hubiera contenido en esta planta de
energía podría haberse trasladado al
área del reactor y podríamos haber visto
un colapso
según los expertos las consecuencias
podrían ser hasta diez veces peores que
el desastre de chernóbil en 1986 la
polilla es la segunda central eléctrica
tomada por el ejército ruso después de
chernóbil la semana pasada representa un
patrón claro de las fuerzas rusas
capturando la infraestructura clave de
ucrania
dos objetivos principales asegurar las
parcelas más importantes que brindan
apoyo a sus fuerzas el segundo es privar
a las fuerzas ucranianas de electricidad
siendo ucrania el tercer país con más
enlaces nucleares en europa está claro
que el ejército ruso seguirá apuntando a
estas plantas en todo el clan